what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
this morning i have been getting a
ton of questions about the spider-man no
way home trailer
a lot of people have been asking for an
update so here we are
last week an official verified twitter
account of somebody who works inside of
the industry
claimed that the trailer would be coming
out on june 10th he was very very
confident in posting this
he stated multiple times that the
trailer was indeed coming on the 10th
and since he had such a good
reputation it made a lot of sense as to
why people would think yes the trailer
is coming out this day
this combined with a picture going
around that showed an amc
logo and it showed the spider-man no way
home trailer release date set for the
10th led us to believe that yes the
trailer was coming today
however for those saying that it could
still come today very
very unlikely marvel and particularly
sony has had a track record recently of
releasing things very early on in the
morning specifically 9am
eastern time and 6 a.m pacific time this
is when they released the venom let
there be carnage trailer this is also
the time that they released the eternals
trailer so we can probably safely assume
that if the trailer was going to be
released today it would already be out
now if you want to know who this person
is you can check my last spider-man
update
trailer video i'm not trying to give
this guy a lot of hate so i won't
mention him by name but he did stick to
a story that he did indeed hear it was
coming on the 10th from a very reliable
source
so things could have changed now
yesterday this was very interesting
the official spider-man no way home
twitter account
did comment on a spider-man trailer meme
they actually retweeted it
quoting it now the meme was posted by
spider-man no way home news and
countdown
and it was this meme right here the
classic meme of the car changing
directions
really really quickly to get off on the
exit with the sign above stating
exit right oh my gosh it's coming today
at 9am eastern time
or go to the left straight which is
don't guess and just wait for the
trailer
and the official spider-man no way home
quote account said please
keep left quote tweeting it now this is
very interesting because
they quote tweeted this yesterday and
the meme was posted five days ago
so that means that sony was very well
aware that people expected the trailer
to come out
today on the 10th and this was kind of
their way of telling us
nope it's not but they are aware that
all of the fans want the trailer
now i don't want to do too many of these
trailer update videos
because i only want to do them if we
truly find out some information or if
there's a good reliable source stating
they think they know when the trailer is
coming i have
two personal sources that i always go to
for trailers who are
pretty much 100 correct when they tell
me a trailer is coming out
i checked with them yesterday i checked
with them again today and my update for
you
is they haven't heard anything so i
don't expect it to come out within the
next day or so
now what remains to be true is is that
the theaters do
indeed have the trailer in the cinema so
we are on the brink of it coming out
it could be any time now perhaps it was
supposed to be today but they moved it
back because they didn't want to release
it the day after loki premiered because
let's face it when the trailer finally
does come out it's pretty much all
anybody is going to be talking about so
maybe they'll give loki a week
and release it next week but i promise
you i'm always looking and listening for
any hint
when the trailer could drop so if i do
hear anything that is legitimate
i'll be sure to do an update video but
if i don't hear anything i won't be
doing a video so if you don't see me
post
i don't know anything just being honest
but be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on the videos when i do know something
don't forget to like the video leave
your comments down below and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof